ein fischtrawler deckel schlagen in der
eisigen beringsee
alle raus zur autobahn fort
47 männer kämpfen ums überleben
alle hatten angst dich auch ich habe zu
gott gebetet und gedacht gleich spring
ich in die beringsee die us-küstenwache
startet eine der schwierigsten
rettungsmissionen aller zeiten
da waren mehr leute im wasser als wir
rausholen konnten es war zu weit draußen
werden die retter rechtzeitig eintreffen
wie viele werden sterben nicht alle
können es schaffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ostern 2008
das 58 meter lange fisch fabrikschiff
alaska ranger kämpft sich durch die
eisige beringsee
es ist in deutsch über alaska gestartet
ziel ist die 800 kilometer entfernte
petrol bank die fischgründe dort zählen
zu den besten der welt
noch läuft alles nach plan
schiffskoch eric haynes arbeitet seit 14
jahren auf der alaska ranger er kennt
die beringsee in und auswendig das würde
ich nur ohne dich machen
manchmal geht das ganz schön wild zu da
draußen du weißt nie wenn das wetter
umschlägt oft passiert genau das
gegenteil von dem was sie vorher sei
der job ist knallhart und gefährlich in
keiner anderen branche in den usa
passieren so viele tödliche
arbeitsunfälle
das versteht nur wer selbst schon mal
tagelang bei zehn meter hohen wellen
gearbeitet hat es gab army ranger die
das nicht gepackt haben sie kann einfach
nicht damit klar
dank
des seit acht monaten der ladungs
kontrolleuren wort er überprüft die
fangmenge
wir arbeiten zwölf stunden schichten
danach haben wir sechs stunden frei
es ist kalt nass und riecht nach fisch
manchmal auch nach vergammelt im 40
die leute wundert sich vielleicht dass
jeder von uns 36.000 dollar in zwei
wochen verdient
aber keiner macht sich klar was wir
dafür leisten müssen
die fahrt zu den fischgründen dauert
zwei tage für die crew die letzte chance
auf eine mütze schlaf bevor der stress
los geht
[Musik]
kapitän jakobsen schicht ist vorbei der
erste offizier david villa das team hat
nicht viele
wechselnde wind bis 27 knoten
ich bin hundemüde
na dann gute nacht
angenehm schlicht
während der erste offizier auf der
brücke die stellung hält überwacht
maschinist ran.de unterdeckt die technik
auf meiner runde habe ich die
temperaturen und messinstrumente
gecheckt reine routine
alles ist ruhig doch dann
um 2 uhr ging der alarm los wasser im
rudermaschine raum gehen
[Musik]
ein bisschen wasser da unten ist ganz
normal dass er dachte ich erst dass wir
kein problem
sicherheitshalber habe ich nach gesehen
und plötzlich schoss mir das wasser
entgegen
ich konnte die wasserdichte tür gerade
noch zu machen
als erstes habe ich david silva auf der
brücke informiert
ich sagte loest den haupt alarm aus und
einem kurs aufs festland
was ist los
haynes auszudrücken ist das nur eine
übung wir haben ein leck in die anzüge
alle jetzt alles schnell jetzt alle raus
kommt schon alle raus das ist keine
übung alle raus ich gehe überall durch
es war schon vorgekommen dass manche den
alarm überhört hatten
aufwachen aufstehen los los los und
steht auf alle zurück
während die männer zur brücke laufen
früchtl an die mit einem kollegen das
ausmaß der überflutung
[Musik]
direkt über dem ruder maschinenraum
standen 3 480 volt transformatoren die
versorgten das ganze schiff mit strom
mir war klar dass es einen kurzschluss
geben würde sobald da wasser rein lief
ohne transformatoren kein strom und ohne
strom keine kontrolle über das schiff
ich hörte dieses quietschen
wie metall das zerreißt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und dann kam das wasser
[Musik]
das wasser steigt rasend schnell an die
kann zwar noch die tür verschließen aber
jetzt ist es nur noch eine frage der
zeit bis das wasser die transformatoren
erreicht
der raum war dicht aber selbst wenn wir
eine pumpe gehabt hätten hätte sie uns
durch die wasserdichten türen nichts
genutzt
brücke hier kämpfen
wir haben bald keinen strom mehr
es gibt keine möglichkeit mehr das
wasser aufzuhalten
ich sagte ich kriege den
belüftungsschacht nicht zu wenn das
wasser so hoch steigt fließt es in den
maschinenraum dann kennt an steuerbord
und gehen unter
notruf an die küstenwache
ratlos komm raus
hier spricht die alaska range
hier spricht die alaska venture roddick
station dritte com die küstenwache in
kodiak alaska ist mehr als 1000
kilometer entfernt
wir sind 200 kilometer westlich von dort
aber position
53 grad
53 minuten
168 grad
sofort starten zwei hubschrauber mit
rettungstauchern einer vom festland der
andere von einem schiff der küstenwache
aus bis sie da sind vergehen mindestens
zwei stunden
falls die männer von bord müssen wie
sollen sie es so langem eiskalten wasser
aushalten kinn hoch
alle waren im steuerhaus und zogen ihre
an zugang das reinste chaos
alle hatten angst sich auch
mit dem überlebensanzug kann man mehrere
stunden im wasser überstehen wenn er
denn richtig passt
ich brauche eine nummer kleiner er ist
zu groß im anzug darfst du keine schuhe
tragen auch keinen kapuzenpulli sonst
funktioniert er nicht
keynes war unsere verbindung zum captain
alles klar passt
er sagte uns dass die küstenwache
informiert war alle versorgt jeder im
anzug ja
wir wussten dass wir in den anzügen
nicht untergehen würden wir brauchten
nur abzuwarten bis die küstenwache kam
für die alaska range aber kommt jede
hilfe zu spät dann kam der kurzschluss
das licht ging aus
auf einmal war es still
es auf diese komischen geräusche als
würden teile herum fliegen ein paar
batteriebetriebene lampen gingen an
das boot kenterte
die alaska ranger neigt sich nach
steuerbord erstaunlich schnell sinkt das
heck ins wasser als würden wir uns
überschlagen
[Applaus]
ahaus die männer rannten nach draußen
das ganze achterdeck stand unter wasser
rettungsboote
ein tanz gegen wind und wellen nichts
läuft nach plan
[Musik]
sie ließen die schlauchboote runter sie
wurden mitgerissen ich zog an der fang
leine aber sie riss ab und weg war es
also los sagt dich zu den jungs ihr geht
jetzt rein so oder so keine weiß wie
lange die männer bei diesen temperaturen
durchhalten werden
es kostet ganz schön überwindung zu
sagen okay ich spring jetzt in die
beringsee
[Musik]
kaum war ich drin schossen 30 oder 40
liter wasser in meinen anzug ich bekam
kaum luft
sechs anzuges zu groß er fühlt sich mit
wasser zu einer lage scheint
aussichtslos
ich sah ein schlauchboot es kam schnell
auf mich zu und bank knallte es gegen
meinen kopf dann wurde ich nach unten
gezogen
irgendwann kam ich wieder hoch und sah
wie das boot weg vor
dann war es verschwunden ich dachte das
war's
bärenstark im wasser um sein leben
kämpft steht dann die noch verzweifelt
an deck
ich sage lichter im wasser treiben das
waren die jungs in ihren anzügen
ich zog an der schnur meiner lampe aber
sie funktionierte nicht
ich musste also an ein schlauchboot im
wasser hätten sie mich nie gefunden
ich nahm meine brille ab und warf sie
ins wasser ich dachte ich würde sie nie
mehr brauchen
der ranger wird jeden moment untergehen
sie stand fast senkrecht ich bin nicht
gesprungen sondern gefallen
das schiff sinkt
[Musik]
1 schaffte es zusammen mit ein paar
anderen auf ein schlauchboot ich fragte
mich wie viele wohl sterben würden ein
paar auf jeden fall
roland weinschenk und der rest der
besatzung treiben im eiskalten wasser
wie viele von ihnen können durchhalten
bis wir verein trifft
ostersonntag 2008 gegen 4.30 am morgen
ist die alaska ranger in der
peitschenden bering see versunken
weniger als die hälfte der 47 köpfigen
besatzung schafft es in die
schlauchboote
die übrigen treiben im eisigen wasser
war ein schatz rettung sun tzu bis zu
groß und wird zur tödlichen falle wenn
jetzt kein wunder geschieht wird er bald
erfrieren
mir war so unfassbar kalt ich konnte
meine hände und füße nicht mehr spüren
von den knien an abwärts war ich total
toll
aber ich gebe die hoffnung nicht auf
immer wieder sagte ich mir sie kommen
gleich sie werden gleich hier sein der
nähere der beiden rettungshubschrauber
ist immer noch mehr als 30 minuten
entfernt für rettungsschwimmer abram
heller ist klar dass die chancen
überlebende zu bergen mit jeder minute
schwinden die wassertemperatur dort
liegt nur knapp über dem gefrierpunkt in
einem rettungs anzug kann man unter
solchen bedingungen höchstens zwei
stunden überleben
47 seeleute in not es ist eine der
grössten rettungseinsätze in der
geschichte der us küstenwache
wir wussten dass wir nicht alle retten
konnten aber wir mussten es zumindest
versuchen zeit war der entscheidende
faktor
vom schlauchboot aus entdeckt ames
einige kameraden im wasser
wir versuchten einige der männer aus dem
wasser zu ziehen in einem schlauchboot
kannst du mehrere tage überstehen im
meer höchstens ein paar stunden
ohne boot steht den männern das wasser
buchstäblich bis zum 1 landes
rettungszug läuft langsam voll schlimmer
noch seine blinkleuchte funktioniert
nicht niemand kann ihn sehen
alles war schwarz ich wusste kaum wo
oben und unten war oder in welche
richtung ich trieb dann sah ich ein
schlauchboot direkt auf mich zukommen
mein anzug war so schwer dass ich mich
nicht allein hochziehen konnte
aber in dieser nacht hatte ich einen
schutzengel
da waren diese beiden typen die zogen
mich rein
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich das war der glücklichste
moment meines lebens
eine stunde lang drücken wir uns die
lunge aus dem leib aber irgendwann
merkten wir dass alle viel zu weit weg
waren
nach fast zwei stunden in der beringsee
rotweinstadt den kampf gegen kälte und
der schöpfung zu verlieren
ich trieb so vor mich hin und irgendwann
wurde es mir zu viel die schmerzen waren
einfach unerträglich ich beschloss
meinen anzug aufzumachen und das wasser
rein zu lassen
ich betete zu gott dachte an meine
eltern meine tochter
sie sollten wissen dass ich bereit war
auf diese weise abzutreten
ich hatte mir noch eine letzte frist
gesetzt
zehn oder 15 minuten dann wollte ich es
tun
und dann hörte ich plötzlich das
geräusch des hubschraubers
er flog auf mich zu und leuchtete mich
an
ich habe gewunken
dann zog er hoch und flog weg
ich dachte was soll das denn
so hart es auch scheint muss noch warten
die retter wollen sich erst einen
überblick verschaffen bevor sie die
männer aus dem wasser ziehen
als der erste helikopter eintraf waren
die überlebenden über hunderte meter
verteilt einige in zwei schlauchbooten
die anderen trieben im wasser
wir hörten ein lautes geräusch und
wussten sofort bescheid
wir winken damit sie wussten dass es uns
gut ging
sie sollten sich erst um die jungs im
wasser kümmern die hatten es nötiger
die retter beginnen außen und arbeiten
sich nach ihnen vor
ein check gehört zu den ersten die aus
dem wasser gezogen werden
dann kam der hubschrauber zurück ich sah
den rettungsschwimmer er sich zu mir
unterließ unter wasser landete
er zog mich mit dem rücken zu sich heran
und gurte mich fest dann wurden wir
hochgezogen ich war als erster rom
kurz darauf trifft abraham heller mit
dem zwei hubschrauber ein
[Musik]
ich schaute mich um und der ernst der
lage war mir sofort klar
da waren mehr leute im wasser als wir
retten konnten
der erste hubschrauber kann nur zwölf
männer aufnehmen in hellas helikopter
passen noch weniger
beide müssen also mehrmals zwischen der
unglücksstelle und die küstenwachen chef
munro hin und her fliegen
die schwimme zum schiffbrüchigen hin und
gebe das signal den korb unter zu lassen
da setze ich ihn rein und ab geht danach
ist der nächste überlebende an der reihe
mehr als fünf stunden lang wollen die
retter einen seemann nach dem anderen
aus dem wasser
ein interview und sie treiben das
rettungsboot führte ein rettungsteam der
küstenwache zu den überlebenden eines
gesunkenen fischereischiff nachdem die
alaska ranger leckgeschlagen war setzte
die kleine lord howe
sie laufen fall das wasser dringt
achtern 1 47 personen an bord
trotz verzweifelter suche fehlt von
einem crewmitglied auch am nächsten tag
jede spur
[Musik]
das schwesterschiff der alaska range an
die alaska wo kommt der küstenwache zu
hilfe nicht alle männer überleben
so einen rettungseinsatz hast du nicht
jeden tag diese aktion war zehnmal
größer als alles was ich wohl im laufe
meiner karriere erleben werde
insgesamt rettete die küstenwache 42
männer
vier crewmitglieder werden tot geborgen
ein fünfter gilt als vermisst seine
leiche wird nie gefunden
das schlimmste an der sache waren die
todesfälle
ich kannte die fünf opfer sehr gut
anständige kerle die gute arbeit
geleistet haben und immer sehr
hilfsbereit waren
wie konnte es zu der katastrophe kommen
warum mussten fünf seeleute sterben
rund 1500 fischerboote sind regelmäßig
in der beringsee im einsatz die
ermittler der küstenwache wollen
sicherstellen dass so etwas nicht noch
einmal passiert
captain michael renz leitet die
untersuchung das verfahren ist an
oberster stelle angesiedelt am marien
board of investigation
das marienbad wollte die ursachen und
umstände des unglücks klären
warum geriet das schiff in diese
furchtbare lage
für sein team braucht trend technisch
versierte offiziere mit viel erfahrung
benjamin hawkins ist einer von ihnen
fünf seeleute zu verlieren war tragisch
es hätte aber auch alle 47 erwischen
kann ebenfalls dabei commander john
das marienbad ergreift alle notwendigen
schritte um zu verhindern dass sich so
ein vorfall wiederholt
die unglücksstelle war zu abgelegen das
meer dort zu tief wir konnten da also
keinen tauchroboter runter schicken
das problem der ermittler sie haben kein
schiffswrack kein einziges physisches
beweisstück die alaska ranger liegt
unerreichbaren grund der beringsee
woher stammte das leck das zu ihrem
untergang führte die ermittler sind auf
die berichte der crew mitglieder
angewiesen
alles was wir hatten waren die aussagen
der zeugen und überlebenden das problem
dabei je mehr zeit vergeht desto
unzuverlässiger werden die erinnerung ob
bewusst oder nicht
jeder steuert seinen teil zum großen
puzzle bei was hatten sie da draußen
erlebt einige wichtige leute wie der
kapitän und der erste offizier waren
leider ums leben gekommen westerland
danke fürs kommen gerne
rodney landes aussage hat besonderes
gewicht er kennt das schiff seit zehn
jahren und hat das leck entdeckt die
wichtigste frage war
als ich den alarm hörte ging ich zum
bruder maschinen rollen
landi berichtet von den enormen
wassermassen die in den maschinenraum
stränden
es war wie eine wand aus wasser
sowas hatte ich noch nie erlebt wir
mussten ein ruder verloren haben
er dachte ein ruder wäre abgefallen
lande hatte das ruder nur wenige stunden
vor dem unglück repariert
das ruder hatte den ganzen tag gelegt
ich musste es mit unmengen schmiere
einfetten
das war nicht normal
stunden später dann das wasser an genau
dieser stelle ins
steuerhaus hier ist prof ich sagte ihm
dass wir ein ruder verloren hatten
haupteinnahmen auslösen
die geschichte klingt plausibel sie
würde erklären warum das wasser am heck
ein dran und auch was als nächstes
geschehe
steuerung reagiert nicht kurz nachdem
das wasser herein strömte verlor der
kapitän die kontrolle über das schiff
lag es am fehlenden ruder es musste das
ruder sein wenn du ein so großes ruder
verlierst dringt viel wasser ein und
zwar schnell das war ein plausibles
szenario
so ein ruder fällt nicht einfach so ab
das mussten wir uns genauer ansehen wie
könnte das abgelaufen sein
um diese frage zu beantworten wird
ermittler und ingenieur ken olsen
hinzugezogen
ich hatte schon öfter mit ihm gearbeitet
und schätzte ihn als gründlichen und
detailversessenen ermittler
posen bezweifelt dass ein verlorenes
ruder der auslöser war
bruder sind so konzipiert dass sie gar
nicht herausfallen können sie haben
einen langen schaft der festen raum
verankert ist das ist der aufbau des
ruders
oben meisterschaft spitzt zu dadurch
entsteht eine sehr feste so genannte
preis passen
das ruder ist mit einem ausgeklügelten
system im rumpf befestigt rosen ist
sicher selbst wenn sich eine der
verbindungen lösen würde könnte es nicht
abfallen
es ist höchst unwahrscheinlich dass sich
das ruder von selbst gelöst hat
es ist geradezu ausgeschlossen dafür
hätte zu viel auf einmal schief gehen
müssen
am ruder hatte es also vermutlich nicht
gelegen aber irgendwo musste das wasser
hier her gekommen sein
was auch immer der grund war es brachte
das 58 meter lange schiff zum sinken
landi behauptet die wasserdichte tür
geschlossen zu haben wie konnte sich das
wasser dann ausbreiten
[Musik]
eigentlich war die sache unter kontrolle
vielleicht wären ein paar maschinen
kaputt gegangen aber das schiff hätte
nicht sinken dürfen wie war das möglich
wir brauchen mehr infos über das die
alaska range ist für die ermittler außer
reichweite immerhin steht ihnen das
schwesterschiff zu verfügen die alaska
war ja die beiden sind nahezu identisch
die alaska war ihr gehörte derselben
reederei
sie musste also in einem ähnlichen
zustand sein wie die alaska
was die untersuchung hervorbringt
ist beunruhigend
wir haben gesehen wie es an bord zuging
wasserdichte türen müssen nun mal
korrekt verschlossen sein wenn sie so
offen stehen wie dort bieten sie
natürlich keinen schutz
durch den türrahmen verlief ein dickes
rohr die eröffnung war nicht abgedichtet
das loch war so gross und lag zwischen
dem ruder maschinenraum und dem
angrenzenden maschinenraum
außerdem gab es löcher in den türen wo
sie komplett durchgerostet waren
schlampig instandhaltung löchrige und
heute sicherheitstüren das alles erklärt
zwar nicht wie das wasser eingedrungen
war sehr wohl aber wie es sich an bord
muss breiten konnte
das bestätigte unseren verdacht dass es
mit der wasserdichtigkeit der alaska
ranger nicht weit her war
die ermittler wissen nun warum sich das
wasser so schnell ausgebreitet hat aber
immer noch nicht was das unglück
verursacht hat
sie befragen ryan shotton ladungs
kontrolleure alaska ranger
weiß er etwas über beschädigte oder
undichte teile
am rumpf vielleicht
er hat was abgekriegt als wir durchs eis
vor
sagt bezieht sich auf einen vorfall ein
paar monate zuvor da könnte was kaputt
gegangen sein
wir waren damals im dichten eis
unterwegs
das ist in der beringsee nichts
ungewöhnlich ist es ist allerdings
gefährlich und die kapitäne müssen sehr
vorsichtig hindurchfahren das war auf
der alaska ranger offenbar nicht der
fall
wir fuhren mit volldampf zwölf knoten
oder so auf jeden fall viel zu schnell
man konnte es richtig krachen hören
das schiff war kein eisbrecher je
nachdem wie dick das eis war könnte es
den rumpf durchaus beschädigt haben
die ermittler sind erstaunt warum sollte
ein erfahrener kapitän so ein risiko
eingehen aber das ist noch nicht alles
bei der fischmeister hatte das steuer
der fisch meister jakkolo der vor uns
dadurch
plötzlich erscheint der fall in neuem
licht wenn jemand anderes als der
kapitän die befehle gegeben hat war das
nicht nur höchst gefährlich sondern auch
gegen das gesetz
die zeugenaussagen bringen einige
verstörende informationen ans licht
offenbar war die alaska ranger viel zu
schnell durch dichtes eis gefahren mit
einer unbefugten person am steuer
kannst du hier mal unterschreiben
da ich für die fangmengen zuständig war
hatte ich oft mit colo zu tun er werte
die fischgründe aus
quito hat die aufgabe das schiff zu den
ertragreichsten fischgründen zu lotsen
mindestens einmal hat er dabei die
aufgaben des kapitäns übernommen
dann sind wir durch das eis durch nicht
mehr lange
fast geschafft
vielleicht haben wir da was abgekriegt
als wir hörten dass der fisch meister
die alaska ranger gesteuert hatte ging
bei uns die warnlampen an
das ist ganz klar ein verstoß gegen die
bestimmungen unter
absolut inakzeptabel
ein verstoß gegen die bestimmungen also
gefährlich auch deshalb weil die crew in
dem moment nicht mehr wusste wer an bord
tatsächlich das sagen hatte
das würde ich nur ohne dich tun
theoretisch hat immer der captain das
kommando an bord so sieht es jedenfalls
die küstenwache fertig damit wieder
runter ja danke aber der fisch meister
war der heimliche chef mit dem hast du
dich lieber nicht angelegt bringen uns
zu den fischen und zum geld ja ja es
gibt keinen hinweis dass corneau das
schiff am tag des unglücks steuerte
trotzdem ist es beunruhigend dass die
vorschriften nicht immer eingehalten
wurden hier und hier da von mir an für
das mal sehen
nahm der kapitän für einen guten fang
noch andere risiken in kauf
das dauert zwei tage
das muss schneller gehen
uns ging es ums geld wir wollten
schneller sein als die konkurrenz
am tag des unglücks verließ die alaska
ranger den hafen um 12 uhr
einige stunden vor ihrem schwesterschiff
der astoria
normalerweise sind immer zwei schiffe
gemeinsam unterwegs geben so können sie
einander im notfall helfen
aber an dem tag wollten wir aus
irgendeinem grund nicht wahr
morde die alaska ranger womöglich
beschädigt weil sie zu schnell unterwegs
war
die sind öfter durch eis gefahren volles
risiko
dafür gibt es jetzt beweise
wir konnten fotos auftreiben die das
schiff im eis zeiten
ein crewmitglied hatte bei einem
früheren tritt fotos und videos
aufgenommen
[Musik]
wir mussten herausfinden dass das leck
verursacht hatte zum glück hat die
küstenwache eine eigene eisbrecherflotte
und das entsprechende fachwissen
ok alles bereit
anhand der bilder schätzen die experten
wie dick das eis war die ursache für den
unfall war es ihrer meinung nach nicht
wenn das eis das schiff beschädigt hätte
während er sofort aufgefallen
es läuft nicht so dass man gegen eine
eisscholle prallt und zwei monate später
ist da plötzlich
tut mir leid das war nicht der übeltäter
am ende gab es keinen hinweis darauf
dass das eis das heck ernsthaft
beschädigt haben könnte
die ermittler stehen wieder am anfang
danke fürs kommen ist erhält was haben
sie übersehen
schiffskoch eric keynes schildert das
unglück aus seiner sicht
ich kam ins steuerhaus und der ging es
hektisch zu
laut ace geschah nach dem stromausfall
etwas seltsames
plötzlich gab es einen ruck
wir wurden nach vorn geschleudert so
was von der grund dafür was passiert bei
einem stromausfall
danach ging ich raus zu den
rettungsbooten wir sinken hatte captain
pete gesagt
aber haynes verliert die kontrolle über
das rettungsboot erst schießt richtung
buch davon
dass salz mit mir durch die handschuhe
in die hände
das ergibt keinen sinn warum schießt ein
rettungsboot noch vorn
das rätselhafte 3 könnte der hinweis
sein den die ermittler gesucht haben
sie stehen kurz davor herauszufinden
warum die alaska ranger gesunken ist
kurz bevor das schiff in den eisigen
fluten der beringsee unterging hat es
sich offenbar von den rettungsbooten weg
bewegt
das könnte die erklärung liefern
[Musik]
ich habe die pläne sehen wir uns das mal
an
wir prüften den bauplan des chefs wir
wollten wissen was da ablief
zunächst sehen sich die experten das
antriebssystem an
die alaska ranger hatte verstell
propeller
sie konnten in den rückwärtsgang
umschalten ohne die laufrichtung zu
ändern stattdessen bestimmte der winkel
der blätter ob das schiff vorwärts oder
rückwärts fuhr
eine spezielle eigenschaft der propeller
lässt die ermittler aufmerken
elektrische motoren sorgen für die
korrekte einstellung der rotorblätter
bei einem stromausfall könnten die
propeller also ungewollt in den
rückwärtsgang und schalten
tatsächlich konnten wir nachweisen dass
die propeller bei einem stromausfall auf
rückwärts umstellten
nachdem der strom ausgefallen war liefen
die maschinen noch im denkbar
ungünstigsten moment vor das schiff
rückwärts
als der koch des schlauchboot herabließ
schoss es nach vorne die besatzung
bemerkte gar nicht dass das schiff
rückwärts fuhr
[Musik]
da das heck bereits mit wasser
vollgelaufen war schob sich das schiff
regelrecht nach unten
um diese bewegung auch zu halten hätte
der kapitän die maschine sofort stoppen
müssen aber das ist nicht passiert
wahrscheinlich verstanden nicht was da
vor sich ging wir können ihn nicht mehr
fragen
ganz gleich warum der kapitän die
maschine nicht gestoppt hat die
ermittler wissen jetzt immerhin warum
beim verlassen des schiffs so vieles
schief ging
aber warum überhaupt so viel wasser
eindringen konnte ist immer noch ein
rätsel
wir wussten dass es am heck angefangen
hatte
aber wir fanden einfach nicht den einen
hinweis der alles erklärte
alle zeugen haben ausgesagt die
ermittler würden sich erneut dem schiff
zu
so einer untersuchung befragen wir
zunächst die crew mitglieder so können
wir nachvollziehen was sich an bord
abgespielt hat genauso müssen wir aber
auch die historie des schiffs betrachten
dazu sehen wir baupläne an und prüfen
welche veränderungen im laufe der jahre
vorgenommen wurden
die ermittler lassen alle verfügbaren
unterlagen kommen und kontrollieren vor
allem die wartungs einträge
hatte das schiff eine schwachstelle
wurden veränderungen vorgenommen gab es
unzulängliche reparaturen
sie wurde in louisiana gebaut um die
bohrinseln zu versorgen die alaska
ranger war baujahr
1973 und wann wurde sie verkauft und
allein fabrik troller umgewandelt die
aufzeichnungen belegen diverse
modifikationen in den letzten 45 jahren
welchen einfluss diese veränderungen
auch das schiff hatten und ob sie im
zusammenhang mit dem unglück stehen
sollte die detailanalyse zeigen
[Musik]
noch einmal wird außen hinzugezogen kann
der ingenieur etwas entdecken
während er die unterlagen durch geht
fällt rosen etwas ungewöhnliches auf im
laufe der jahre mussten am heck immer
wieder kleinere risse gekittet werden
könnte das die entscheidende spur sein
auf jeden fall zeigte es dass das heck
stark beansprucht war
olsen stößt auf ein foto das während
einer reparatur aufgenommen wurde es
zeigt die halterungen die die propeller
mit dem schiffsrumpf verbinden
auf dem bild sieht man einen typen beim
schweißen und
und da fragt man sich doch was schweißt
er da an den streben rum
das ist seltsam die streben haben keine
beweglichen teile sie gehen so gut wie
nie kaputt
olsens entdeckung könnte der durchbruch
sein treffer er hat eine theorie woher
das leck stammte
mehr als ein jahr nach dem untergang der
alaska ranger stehen die ermittler kurz
vor der lösung des falls
ich glaube wir haben da was eine reihe
von reparaturen am heck des schiffs
schweißarbeiten hier
das foto war der aha moment diese
reparatur schien überhaupt keinen sinn
zu ergeben
offenbar wurden dabei spannungsrisse
gekettet olsson ist überzeugt dass diese
von nachträglich eingebauten court düsen
statt
die großen ringe umgeben die propeller
sie sorgen für mehr schub und helfen
sprit zu sparen jeder ring wiegt und
eine tonne
dort lösen müssen fest in dir um
struktur integriert werden sind sie nur
an der hülle befestigt kann das den
rumpf beeinträchtigen und zu rissen
führen
vielleicht waren die schweißarbeiten
nötig um einen stümperhaften einbau
auszugleichen das sind die modifizierung
pläne
bei seinen recherchen stößt olsen auf
zwei methoden um die düsen sicher zu
montieren a
und b
welche haben sie verwendet keine
die düsen würden nicht mit dem rahmen
verschweißt 19
anstatt den rumpf aufzumachen und die
halterungen richtig zu verankern haben
sie sie einfach außen dran gehängt das
war ein fehler
die konstruktion war ständiger
vibrationen durch die propeller
ausgesetzt
irgendwann bekam die schweiz stellen
risse
in den wartungs unterlagen konnten wir
sehen dass bei fast jedem aufenthalt im
trockendock rund um die propeller
reparaturen gemacht würden
falls auf der steuerbordseite eine
schweißnaht gerissen war könnte das die
ursache für das leck gewesen sein
die halterungen sachen genau unter dem
ruder maschinenraum
rodney landes bericht
[Musik]
die schweißnaht verlief so nahm
bruderschaft dass selbst ein erfahrener
seemann wie lang die den wahren grund
für das leck nicht sofort erkennen
konnte
an dem punkt wurde uns klar
so muss es gewesen sein
zwei jahre nach dem untergang der alaska
ranger kommt die küstenwache zu
folgendem schluss
eine der propeller halterungen brach ab
und riss dabei ein loch in den rumpf
große mengen wasser strömten in den
ruder maschinen
was ist los alle zur brücke sofort
wegen unzureichender
sicherheitsvorkehrungen konnte sich das
wasser schnell ausbreiten
nein nein nein schnell raus hier die
crew konnte nichts dagegen tun
[Musik]
das eindringende wasser führte zu einem
stromausfall der
dafür sorgte dass die propeller in den
rückwärtsgang schalteten
während sich das heck ins meer schon
versäumte es der kapitän die maschinen
zu stoppen
das schiff fuhr mit volldampf nach unten
wir gruben unser eigenes grab
fünf männer starten in den eisigen
fluten
in seinem abschlussbericht ermahnt das
mainboard jene reedereien die mit
niedrigen wartungs standards das leben
ihrer seeleute aus spiel setzen
wir kamen zu dem schluss dass der
gesetzgeber der küstenwache noch mehr
handhabe übertragen sollte
wir müssen die fischerboote regelmäßig
inspizieren von sicherstellen dass sie
vernünftig gewartet werden im interesse
der seeleute
das drama der alaska ranger hat für viel
aufsehen gesorgt das hat dazu
beigetragen die sicherheitsstandards
älterer fischerboote anzuheben
die situation der fischer hat sich
deutlich verbessert
trotzdem setzen wir uns auch weiterhin
für ihre sicherheit auf see ein
der untergang der erlass granger hat
fünf männer das leben gekostet dank der
großangelegten rettungsaktion
haben 42 crewmitglieder überlebt
es war cool ein fischer zu sein aber
danach war für mich schluss damit
ich habe dieses schiff geliebt mit der
ranger ist ein teil von der
untergegangenen
ich denke noch oft an die jungs die es
nicht geschafft haben